[ Cheering and applause ]
That's --
You know what?
-I'm so confused.
-That's a lot of love.
-Yeah, that's so sweet.
I'm like genuinely taken aback.
-Yeah, good.
-I don't know what to do now.
-I feel that way, too, though.
-Okay.
-You've only been
on our show once,
but I feel like I want to be
friends with you.
I love you.
-Should we?
-Yeah.
-Done.
-You want to?
-Yeah.
Cool.
[ Laughter, cheering, applause ]
It's a high--
You totally did it.
I know, I know.
How is "Saturday Night Live"
going?
-It's going really well,
actually.
Everyone is really cool.
It's very comfortable.
I feel like I'm still --
I forget that they've been
doing it for so long.
So, like things happen
[ Snaps fingers ] so quickly.
-Oh, yeah.
-We were deciding
the sketches the other day,
and I remember
I was sitting in the chair
across from Lorne Michaels,
and everyone started
getting up and leaving.
And I looked at Lorne, and I was
like, "Oh, are we done?"
And he was like, "Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, we moved on."
-I was sitting there
for maybe 30 seconds.
Like it did not feel --
-There's no more scripts
to read. That's it.
-We go through things
so quickly.
-Is it because you're savoring
every moment?
-Maybe, I guess you could say.
But also, at the same time,
I'm so in awe
of everybody around me.
I'm also,
I guess, being really quiet.
Because I was looking and,
as we were taking the sketches,
he was like,
"Is there a sketch you prefer?
This one or this one?"
I said, "Oh, I think
that one's funnier,"
and he said, "Okay.
Well, then say something."
And I was like, "Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. Exactly right.
-"Yeah, you're right."
-Obviously, you learned
some lessons
out of "Saturday Night Live."
-I think I'm learning.
I'm picking up on it now.
-Yeah, it's the best crew
up there, the best writers,
the best hair and makeup.
It's so much fun.
-Yeah, they're so seasoned.
-Yeah, it's great.
You're gonna be fantastic.
Break a leg this Saturday.
Come on.
We'll be watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We'll be watching
and supporting.
Last time we were here, we were
talking about "Wednesday."
And, man, oh, man, it turned out
one of the biggest shows
in the world on Netflix.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And since you've been here,
it got picked up for Season 2,
so there you go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
More work.
Work breeds work.
Now you got to work more.
-Yeah.
No, I'm very excited.
-Do you have any idea
where you're gonna go
this season at all?
-I don't know.
I think we just started
getting a writers' room together
and kind of talking about it.
And everyone's
being really cool.
I think we want to up kind of
the horror aspect a little bit
and then get Wednesday
out of the romantic situation
and just let her be
her own individual
and fight her own crime...
-Yeah!
-...and battles [indistinct].
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-You've been nominated
for every single award.
Congratulations.
Well-deserved. I, honestly...
-Thank you.
-...I really can't get enough.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Do you like going to these award
shows and doing the whole thing?
-I don't think --
going to award shows,
the 30 minutes before,
it's the most sick
you'll ever feel
in your entire life.
You're so anxious, so nervous,
so whatever, and especially --
You're with people
that you admire.
Like the SAG Awards, it was,
you know, all of your peers,
everyone who's a part of SAG,
so you're seeing
these people like --
-You had a hot table.
I loved your table.
-Yeah, I had
a really cool table.
-Yeah, Zendaya was there.
-Yeah, well, Zendaya,
I feel like we've kind of --
we've met and not met
so many times, I feel like,
this time, we were actually
able to have
a nice conversation.
But I was kind of freaking out
because she was sitting next
to Paul Mescal, who I think is
so talented and so good.
And I was so nervous
to meet him,
and I knew he was gonna be
at my table.
And I remember him --
he introduced himself to me
when I wasn't expecting it.
-Ooh.
-So he was like,
"Oh, hi! Nice to meet you.
I'm Paul."
And I was so nervous,
I kind of couldn't look him
in the eye,
so I fear that
it was a bit like --
-You were like, "Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
-"Yeah, 'Aftersun' was great.
-Oh, my God.
-You did that."
-I've done that before,
and you go, "Oh, my God.
That's so rude."
But you're just nervous,
and "You get me
at the wrong moment."
-I have that happen so many
times to me at award shows.
-But, no, the best thing,
I think,
was you and Aubrey Plaza
at the SAG Awards.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It was so -- it was so funny,
and it destroyed.
It was a great bit.
And then the Internet went
on fire.
And it was like, "We want
to see you guys in a movie.
Do anything together.
Do something. Play sisters."
-Yeah, I would do anything
with her.
She's another one of those
people where everyone
kept saying, "Oh, you remind me
of Aubrey,"
or, you know, "Oh, you two
should get together,"
and we just never did
until we were backstage then.
And she just looked at me,
she said, "Hey, you!
[ Snaps fingers ]
Get over here."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
See? She's so funny.
-Yeah, she was really cool.
-She's smart.
She's everything, yeah.
Can we talk about "Scream VI"?
-Yeah.
-It's a big deal.
Tomorrow.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's out tomorrow.
"Scream VI" is set in New York.
Oh, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
New York City,
where we do our show.
How do we set up this "Scream"?
-Well, this time,
it's kind of --
Well, yeah, it's a different
setting, which I mean,
the "Scream" franchise
has never left Woodsboro,
so I think that it makes
for a lot more
an intimidating story,
I would say.
You know, Ghostface can come
for you on the subway,
push you off a skyscraper
building.
You know.
-Yeah.
-New York City
has got a lot of places.
-Everything about this --
[ Laughter ]
I think everything about this
movie is just bigger
and scarier, and also Ghostface
is just so much more brutal.
I feel like
he's very unforgiving,
and everyone's a victim,
not just the lead cast,
which makes it better.
-Now, do you know,
when you get the script,
do you know who Ghostface is,
or do they change the script
so that you don't really know
who it is?
-Sometimes they give us
different scripts,
different endings.
This time around,
they just didn't give us
the third act at all.
[ Laughter ]
-So you gotta see the movie
to find out who the killer is?
-Yeah, now you just don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone usually finds out
at least by the last two weeks.
-Yeah.
-But they try to play games.
-Congrats on that,
and congrats on "SNL."
You're gonna be fantastic.
Alright. Now, Jenna, here's how
this works, okay?
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
Jenna, you pick the first box.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Three?
[ Drumroll ]
-You are choosing 3.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Huh, it looks --
it looks light.
-[ Groans ]
-Yeah, too late.
Too late to act now.
-Now?
-Too late to act now.
So, I know it's light.
Are you going to lie or are you
going to tell the truth?
Very interesting.
Jenna Ortega.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Tapping ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, I see.
You're making sounds.
You're distracting me.
Yeah.
-You don't know what's
happening to you.
-What is in your box?
-Can I be honest with you,
Jimmy?
-Yes, you can always be honest
with me.
-I don't -- I'm -- I'm not sure
I even understand
what's happening here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You don't understand
what's happening?
So, this thing that you are now
looking at,
you don't understand.
-I don't.
-Can you describe it for me?
-I fear of being a bit too
on the nose,
but it is
"Addams Family"-themed.
-Yeah. Well, we knew that you
were coming on.
-Cousin Itt.
Yeah, well, it would make sense.
-It would make sense.
We did book you.
-Cousin Itt.
He happens to be reading
a magazine of some sorts,
perhaps like "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca edition?
[ Laughter ]
-Cousin Itt is reading
a magazine
and it could be "Vanity Fair."
-Yeah, on a nice bench.
-A bench? So, he's outside.
-Yeah, he's outside.
It seems to be a nice park,
Central Park,
if you will, in New York.
-Oh, it's New York.
So, he's in Central Park?
-There may be a corgi involved.
-It's a corgi?
-Yeah.
-So, Cousin Itt owns a dog?
[ Laughter ]
Cousin Itt owns a pet?
-I guess so.
-So there's a lot of hair.
There's a lot of hair.
Is Cousin Itt wearing a hat?
-Yes, he is.
Like he always does.
He always has a hat.
-Yeah.
But if you took your time
answering that,
that would mean
that you're lying.
So, I think that you are...
...telling the truth!
[ Drumroll ]
-I am.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Wow!
"Vanity Fair."
-Honestly --
-Chewbacca? It's weird.
That is odd.
-Yeah, I should've lied
because it's way too niche.
Like the "Vanity Fair" Chewbacca
article, instantly --
-Yeah, we wouldn't do that.
Alright.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
[ Drumroll ]
-2! 2!
-Oh, my back!
-I already did that.
-[ Groaning ]
Ooh!
-Ohh!
-Ooh! Here we go.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a painting.
-Painting of what?
-Famous, famous,
famous painting.
Something you'd see in a museum.
-I feel like you have to be
more specific on this game.
-I don't think -- I don't want
to be more specific.
[ Laughter ]
I want to be vague.
Think of a famous painting.
-Oh, so it's just a painting.
Don't tell me it's
the Edvard Munch, the --
-"The Scream"?!
-Ooh.
-Ooh, that's interesting.
-That's a bit on the nose, too.
-Well, you do have a movie
called "Scream" coming out.
So, that's pretty funny,
not niche.
[ Laughter ]
Now,
now, here's what makes it funny.
It's not -- The painting's face.
It's Colonel Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
-Colonel Sanders is very funny.
-Colonel Sanders is funny.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
In fact, I want to keep it
and hang it in my bedroom
because I love it.
[ Laughter ]
It's so funny. There you go.
It's "The Scream,"
Colonel Sanders Scream.
-Honestly, I feel like
Colonel Sanders is pretty funny.
[ Laughter ]
Just to repeat myself.
-He's not supposed to be funny.
He's selling food.
-I think it's -- I think --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like you might be telling
the truuuuu...
-[ Shouts indistinctly ]
-Uhhh...
-Did you just say something
in Spanish?
Wait, what did you just say?
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
I feel like you just
helped somehow.
-Maybe it's a lie. Maybe it's
a lie. Maybe it's a lie.
Maybe too on-the-nose
references.
I'm sorry, I'm taking forever.
It's just 'cause
I really don't know.
I don't really care.
I'm going to go with truth.
[ Laughter ]
-No! I was lying!
[ Buzzer ]
The "Mona Lisa."
-Oh, my God. You just took --
-Really a good actor.
Thank you.
-No.
-Did you say my acting skills
are fantastic?
That's so nice of you.
-Yeah, that's ex-- Yes.
-Thank you!
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Time to pick a number.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
One more.
[ Drumroll ]
-I'm serious.
-This is it.
This is it.
For all the marbles.
Jenna Ortega, pick a nombre.
Uno!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wow, it's a bowling ball.
It's a bowling ball.
Wow!
Alright, so it really is heavy.
Oh, my goodness. Alright.
-What if I broke it
or something?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Sorry.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-Why are you being --
[ Laughter ]
Why are you being so serious?
♪♪
-Um...
-Roots, your music is like
giving me trips or something.
[ Laughter ]
I'm tripping out.
I'm like, "Wah, wah."
-Uh, we have, um...
There's a Bobblehead.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-It's a Bobblehead.
-It's a Bobblehead?
-A Bobblehead of Peter Pan.
Um, he seems to be in a bit more
of a --
like a --
like a business attire.
[ Laughter ]
He's got kind of like
the Leonard Cohen --
-Peter Pan in like
a business suit?
-Peter Pan
in a business-esque suit.
He's wearing a hat that's a bit
more of like
a Leonard Cohen fedora hat.
And he's --
[ Laughter ]
-Leonard Cohen.
That's so funny.
-But is also in a cowboy hat
with wheels
and marshmallows all in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you just naming words?
Are you just saying words?
-There are so many marshmallows
in there.
-You just said 20 words.
Peter Pan is on a marshmallow?
-No, there's --
So, cowboy hat.
-Uh-huh.
-Truck wheels.
-Yeah.
-Bunch of marshmallows in there.
In there is
a Bobblehead figurine
of Peter Pan wearing
a business suit.
[ Laughter ]
-If you're lying,
it's pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
You have a good imagination.
If you're telling the truth,
props to my props department.
[ Laughter ]
Props to props.
Welcome back
to "Props to Props."
-Yeah.
-Jenna, I feel like
we're besties.
And if we are, I would know
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
And I think you are...
[ Drumroll ]
[ Laughter ]
...telling ze truth!
[ Drumroll continues ]
-I lie.
-Oh, my God!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Come on!
Don't eat that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Jenna Ortega, everybody!